una vez
con el cuerpo de la creación del poema
pero el manual del conductor continental
oportunamente frente
a veces llegaban por el cliente
i
por eso
[Música]
sin embargo
los tipos de gestos
y no voy a ir
en julio comenté con su contingente
y
en todo el periodo porque las mujeres
a todas las demás
cuando ya no tanto
[Música]
y
con sus criterios
y de otro
[Música]
es demasiado pobre
a las 21 de abril nivel de estas
etiquetas un agente lo mediante
con el objetivo de ayudar mucho
[Música]
pero
el tiempo estimado
[Música]
golpearla
la luna
[Música]
palabras como mentes fuertes se pueden
buscar la verdad
tienen otros comentarios
pero a mí no
no creo que un hombre es algo así
muy bueno
tan fuerte
y
el mundo
y mucho
[Música]
también estaba bueno
lehmann
el puente
no importa todos los grupos
porque todos
todos
bueno
como puede
[Música]
lo que os
y aprender
tendríamos que hacer
el estilo de estudio
tienen buena historia
y me siento bien
[Música]
vamos a tener
el momento en tiempos mejores
cualificación
la mayoría
como yo
y
[Música]
después
y
no
[Aplausos]